A record and Sun.
Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the broadcast
and we're on right now,
which I may get it.
So you can see that had twitter for like
cooking up twice.
That's a terrible way to start off the
show.
No one heard that shit.
What are you talking about?
People online right now?
There's 100 people online.
I'm sure.
See how many people we got?
90 four people.
Did anybody hear that?
Tastes terrible.
God Damn Joke.
Wow.
This is blockies.
Fuck.
Look how goofy looks.
Cool.
Serious fucking delay to what's
happening.
Eddie and Joe,
why don't we come back to Philly.
Will be back to philly eventually.
Um,
I don't know when the UFC is going to be
back in Philly,
but people have been calling for young
Eddie Bravo to be on the Joe Rogan
podcast here.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
there is Eddie Bravo man.
There's like a five second delay.
It's awkward.
Uh,
so we're here in Charlotte,
North Carolina.
Pretty fucking bad ass town.
And it,
it's nice hair and people are all
friendly.
Yeah,
I like it.
I rented a car for the first time coming
to a UFC city and you get to know the
city a lot better when you have to know
what the hell you're going,
you know,
we're so used to jumping in bands and
and just not paying attention and we
really don't even know anything about
the city.
Renting cars is the key.
Yeah.
Drive around and get to know the place.
I like it here,
man.
It's real.
It's all spread out.
It's a,
you know,
it's like no congestion creep,
oral friendly.
There's no tension here.
It's a good size city.
Charlotte's a good size city.
It's not too crazy.
Yeah,
the super friendly.
I drove into the weigh ins and they were
charging for parking and since I drove
and then go into where the UFC van,
I pulled up to the girl taking them on
and go,
listen,
I actually work for the UFC.
I just don't have my laminate but I'll
pay whatever.
She's like,
no,
just drive right in.
I just drove right in.
Park went up to.
I needed to get back stage and again I
didn't have my credentials.
So there's like security,
they're like North Carolina security.
I'm like,
I need to get my credentials.
Is there any like,
I mean,
can you direct me to a spot where I
could speak to someone because just go
backstage and just walked backstage and
went right in zero security.
Now you're telling stalkers how they
could meet providers,
you know,
next time it's going to Carolina,
you have some ammo.
Let's.
Okay.
I can't read this shit too far.
He's your eyes bad.
Is My eyes bad?
Be Bad?
Well,
we froze up.
Ustream kind of sucks,
you know,
they all suck at these things because
the Internet is not quite ready for this
shit yet.
Uh,
so me just answer questions and share
what stuff have we done in town.
We haven't done shit in town.
Really.
I went river rafting last Monday.
Last time I had a show at,
um,
a place called Ms Dot south.
Then a lot of fun.
Great crowd,
good times.
Then afterwards it was a gentleman's
club down the street.
We had to bring some dudes came to my
show.
They had a two books.
They wanted eddy design.
It's actually kind of funny story and
they wanted a eddie the science books,
so we had to get the books over to
Eddie,
but um,
and then we went to a waffle house and
fucked up some waffles.
Yeah,
that was a good times.
Good Times my friend.
Good Times.
What do I think about synthetic
cannabis?
That's legal.
That's kind of interesting.
Shit.
You know about that man?
They have the marinol.
No,
no,
it's a synthetic cannabis.
It's like,
you know how they had that,
uh,
when the whole balco scandal came out,
what it was,
was a steroid that they had made.
It was just slightly different from
regular steroids in was undetectable and
tests because the regular steroids,
what they were looking for in the test,
they weren't looking for this stuff.
Well that's the same thing with this.
There's a synthetic cannabis that you
could smoke it as the same effects and
it doesn't show up in tests.
What does it look like?
It looks like wheat and actually it
looks like.
Wait.
Yeah,
it looks like not a plant.
Yeah.
And they just wow.
They've just grown it and I mean,
it makes sense.
I mean they've figured out a way to um,
I didn't know about the botanists have
figured out a way a long time ago to put
thc into other things.
They like,
there was an article online where there
was this guy was trying to put the
tomatoes,
get tomatoes to grow tac,
like they can fuck with plants and have
them,
you know,
different plants produce more vitamin C
and different plants do certain things
and you know,
they're,
they're trying to figure out how to make
these,
uh,
I guess they have figured out how to,
how to make we'd.
That doesn't show up in drug tests.
Pretty crazy.
And it's legal.
So like if you worked for ups or
something like that and they drug test
you and you can't smoke weed,
you can smoke the fuck out of this
stuff.
How long has this been out?
It's been out for awhile,
man.
They're trying to make it illegal.
It's a big deal.
Now we're trying to make it illegal.
30 bitches.
So you could sell in any way that
they're selling on in high times
magazine is where they send all that
bullshit.
That stuff's not real at all.
Yeah.
What's up with that shit is wack.
That is the weakest shit ever.
That fake weed and they sell that is so
dumb.
But they say that that's like a big part
of their advertising revenue.
I think that's just because they're
fucking lazy.
You know,
you're telling me that everyone's so
afraid of we.
They can't advertise their products and
your magazine come on,
but yet you can sell fake weed.
You're just ripping people off.
That's all that is.
That stuff doesn't get anyone high.
But this other stuff does.
That sort of stuff is real.
Shit.
Eddie.
Eddie's here.
Talk about Ufos already.
Michael Chavela the guy from a k one and
you know a dream.
You know the Australian dude that we
hung out with in Australia,
he's A.
I'm a big Ufo guy and he was a downtown
Roswell Museum and he actually saw a Ufo
and took photos of it and shit.
Fuck yeah,
that's pretty crazy.
I mean,
who the fuck knows,
man?
You have any UFO questions?
Go ahead and shoot.
Did I finish the entire plate of food?
You Post on twitter?
I finished most of it.
I fuck up some food folks,
especially after shows after shows like
a fuck up some food,
you know,
as the UFC to burn off a lot of energy.
Just talking.
It doesn't seem like you would,
but you do
that.
He actually flap on Saturday.
What does that mean?
Oh,
oh,
he's going down.
Did I watch that train wreck?
Prison wives of the Discovery Channel?
No.
There's a show about chicks whose
husbands are in prison.
Oh,
I might have to see what channel
discovery channel.
It might be good.
Oh,
the history channel documentary.
I know what I saw.
Yeah,
I saw that one too.
That was kind of interesting.
That was the best documentary I've ever
seen on your first.
Uh,
definitely.
I know what I saw.
I didn't have.
It was one of those rare documentaries
that let you have those two.
Didn't have like that.
The other side,
you know,
they didn't have a guy going,
well you know,
it's all just mythology and you know,
it's in their minds and they're all
crazy and why are they landing in Idaho
all the time?
Why not in big cities?
And they didn't have any of those guys
because it was so ridiculous because
that's so many high ranking military
officers coming forward that one case in
England on a US base with that 80
witnesses and three of the guys went up
to it and touched it and wrote down
notes on it and they all came up in the
Ministry of Defense.
Totally.
They said this is not a concern of
national defense.
That's what.
That's the content.
So that is that alone right there.
It's pretty crazy.
And those Arizona Arizona Lights,
I mean people saying there's,
I don't know how many witnesses,
but
the Arizona life's pretty crazy.
I know a dude who lives in Arizona saw
that.
He said he saw the fucking,
the big pyramid thing flying through the
air and they sang.
It's like bigger than a aircraft carrier
football field.
He said it was gigantic.
You said it was a gigantic,
big pyramid shaped thing flying to
Scotland.
Who the fuck knows,
you know,
my,
my take on Ufo.
Um,
they've been really were aliens that
could come here from another planet.
What do you think that there will be so
silly that they would,
they wouldn't disguise themselves.
I think a lot of the shit we see all the
time could be Ufo as I told you about
that crazy dude that told me that,
uh,
he was showing me pictures of clouds.
There's a dude that I know is a
comedian,
is a very nice guy and uh,
the other day,
uh,
I'm talking to him at the Improv and a
homeboy says,
what do you think about Ufo?
And I said,
well,
you know,
hey man,
uh,
I don't know.
I haven't seen one,
but I don't discount the idea.
I mean it's certainly possible.
Obviously we have spaceships and for
someone from other planets,
if they're more intelligent than us,
for sure they could have space ships.
So he starts pulling on his iphone and
the dude has like dozens of pictures of
clouds on his phone.
And I'm,
I'm like,
what,
what does that,
what do you think about this?
We'll get this right there,
and I go to cloud.
And he goes,
yeah,
but it's an unusually shaped cloud.
Look at it.
And I'm like,
oh no,
he's crazy.
I'm like,
he's fucking crazy.
This dude takes pictures of clouds,
all different clouds.
And he's convinced that these clouds are
Ufos.
But at one point on one hand you've got
to think like if you really are so
superintelligent that you can visit from
other planets,
why would you,
you know,
for sure we're working on cloaking
devices right now.
There is already this Japanese jacket
that's been invented that basically
takes an image of what's behind you and
broadcast it on the front of the jacket.
It's basically like Predator type shit.
You remember from the movie the
Predator.
And they really have this already.
I mean it's not perfected,
but we can't travel to other planets yet
either.
You know what I'm saying?
So if someone from another planet is so
much more highly intelligent than we
are,
that they can actually travel here from
other galaxies are or older other solar
systems for sure.
They've figured something like this out.
So when you're seeing the sky,
I mean,
it's very possible,
you know that what you're seeing is if,
if there are Ufo as you would see an
image of the sky behind the behind the
UFL being projected onto you.
So you wouldn't see shit,
you know,
that said you,
if you could take into account how many
Ufos are reported.
I mean,
it's like there's some ridiculous amount
of,
of Ufo is reported and if you take into
account how many people see and don't
report,
they don't say anything because they
want to look foolish.
You know,
that's a,
that's a lot of Goddamn Ufo.
False.
I think a lot of what people are seeing
is military jets that they don't
understand.
Like when I was in,
um,
we did fear factor down near Edwards air
force base and they had stealth bombers
flew up.
Dude,
you,
you see a stealth bomber.
You think that's a goddamn space.
Yet,
yeah,
the French government did a test with
some.
There was a serious,
a review of all the.
There's like 50,000
or something,
something 50,000
since certain year there's probably way
more,
but they came to the conclusion that I'm
95 percent of reported cases can be
explained away with that,
like military others,
high ranking military or this top secret
military planes and different lights,
but they said five percent,
most likely our aircraft from other
worlds.
Well,
I don't know why they can say aircraft
from other worlds because I don't
necessarily think we have a.
it's more likely to take inventory of
what exists in this moment.
They're saying they're saying that
that's
probably what that is.
More of.
The more likely it's some
extraterrestrial craft then.
I mean they got.
There's five percent of it.
Just because it's not from our
government or the Russian government
doesn't necessarily mean even as from
another planet.
We don't know what the fuck is in the
ocean.
No,
no,
no.
It's a lot of Ufo is get cited.
Called.
There was a whole a history channel
documentary about that and people go,
well,
that's ridiculous.
That's nonsense.
That's silly.
It's silly that you can set a fucking
picture that you could take this fucking
thing and send a video across the sky
into somebody else's phone in Australia.
That's way more silly than some people
from another planet have visited here or
that there's something living in the
ocean,
especially when you have guys like x
Pentagon,
high ranking officials like Philip
Corso,
who before he died,
he wrote a book and he explained his job
in the government in the Pentagon was
taking crashed ufo stuff,
taking it to like a Hughes aircraft and
Lockheed and all these different
aerospace companies to reverse engineer.
He's saying he was like,
there's many interviews on youtube with
Philip course.
He's dead now.
He was on dateline and they try to like,
ridicule,
but you know,
um,
how do you.
J Dot Allen Hynek too is another
excellent example that jail.
And Hank was the guy who was in charge
of project blue book and he was told to
by the government when they had this
thing to explain away everything,
swamp gas,
you know,
a mass hysteria,
anything they could do to explain away
ufo cases,
but as he became more involved in
project blue book and as he investigated
more and more sightings and you know,
and dealt with more and more evidence,
he became absolutely convinced that you
have.
Those were real.
So Jay Allen Hynek,
who was,
you know,
a guy actually working to discredit ufo
eventually came out and started a
supporting the whole Ufo movement.
So I think it's,
it's not,
it's not ridiculous to think that we've
been visited.
I mean we go to the Congo all the time
and stare at chimpanzees,
you know,
I mean if you were from another planet
and you had the ability to travel here,
why wouldn't you check out people?
People are fucking completely
ridiculous.
They're probably fascinating.
I mean,
what would be more.
We studied lower forms of animals.
We always have.
And we have been doing this since the
beginning of time.
I mean,
people,
people have always been interested in
botany and we've always been interested
in studying different monkeys and in
different weird animals and other.
I mean that's the whole thing with
Darwin,
you know,
he took a,
it took a,
an account of all these different
animals that he came across.
We've always done shit like that and I
think if we were a much higher
intelligence than human beings,
we would want to do that with people
would want to check out and see what the
fuck people are up to see if people are
evolving,
see what the bottleneck is as far as
like social and cultural evolution and
technological evolution and whether or
not our technology is surpassing our,
our ability as a human being like too to
make rational decisions.
And I think it probably is right now.
You know,
they just fired up the large Hadron
collider yesterday.
You know,
yesterday was the first test
north who is watching,
what is that equal out too?
I think that looks like a nail due to
reno.
I don't know,
it looks like a whole hot to,
you don't know a hot is a,
is a Portuguese Brazilian guy say pull
out all the time.
It's like,
it sort of means like fuck or balls.
It means like a bunch of different
things.
They say it all the time.
Ms Dot bawls.
I think it just a budges yeah,
yeah.
I heard a bunch of different
translations,
but to me too is the fighting vampire,
you know what I mean?
Is a famous bar,
gracie black belt and um,
I guess he looks like Dracula or
something.
So I called him last.
He's the Brazilian vampire.
That's funny.
Am I not going to accommodate?
Yeah,
I'm going to compensate.
That shit's in the.
I'm going to leave in a half an hour.
We're chilling here in the hotel room.
We're getting ready to go down there and
commentate.
Yeah.
I'm like,
what do I think about scientology?
I think it's awesome if you're gay and
you want to cover it up and they're
really good at that shit.
It's all nonsense.
All,
all religions are nonsense.
You know?
You know,
just as much as I know as far as like
what happens when you die.
No one knows.
I didn't let you know what.
I think religion is awesome if you do it
right,
if you do it right,
if you do the right thing and help your
neighbors.
Like my grandma was hardcore Catholic
and I wouldn't try to convince her like
if she was still allowed to get out of
that,
she was doing.
She was going to church every day and
that praying is like meditating.
She was meditating.
So I think just like having the healthy
heart.
You could.
Some people can do kettlebells,
some people could run on a treadmill,
some people run stairs,
some people do martial arts.
That's for a healthy heart and it all
works.
And I think religion,
whether you're doing the Jesus or the
ally or the Buddha or meditation or
yoga,
it doesn't really matter.
As long as you get your frequency at the
right spot with the universe.
It doesn't matter if you do the Jesus
thing,
you know?
So I think that.
I think you're right.
I think whatever you,
whatever it gets you in that right
frequency,
you can worship your iphone.
If you actually believe that and you can
meditate to your iphone,
I think the universe don't give a fuck.
They're like,
how are you going to get to our
frequency?
That's all that.
My real problem is people.
The real problem is the same.
Do you know what it is?
It's the same thing when whenever,
when someone believes in something,
even if they believe in something
completely irrational,
they want everyone else to believe in
it,
to everyone else to be on their team.
That's why like if you ever talked to
people that use windows and they find
out that you use Mac and they're like,
what the fuck man,
I use Mac for faggots and then he crazy
like they want you to use windows and
it's like want you to be
Muslim?
They want you to be a scientologist.
They want you to be a Catholic.
You know,
that's the real problem is that people
want you to,
to
two
subscribed to their ideology,
but the idea behind it,
you know,
being a better person and you know,
and treating everybody as if they're
yourself and you know that all that,
that's the way to go.
I mean,
it really is,
but the fucking handing out the basket
and fucking kids and all that other shit
that,
you know,
involved in relationships with kids.
I have to admit I'm not into that.
I'm against that.
I saw that deliver us from evil.
They recommended.
Come on.
He recommended this documentary and you
guys should check it out to.
It's called deliver us from evil.
If you want to find out how fucked up
the Catholic Church really is.
Oh my God.
Is this incredible?
Yeah.
Well,
I couldn't watch the whole thing.
I've watched about an hour and 10
minutes to get to the point where it
turns out that guy's done like hundreds
of kids.
Yeah.
I couldn't take it.
I wanted to kill him.
I,
I mean,
it's,
it's really a really sick,
sick documentary about this priest who
is responsible for molesting hundreds of
kids and you know,
they covered it up.
They kept moving on,
they moved them all over the country and
uh,
really it's incredible.
And that's what's going on right now.
That gigantic scandal that's happening
right now with the pope.
The pope had knowledge of all this
fucking shit that was going on.
There's so many pedophiles,
not all pedophiles.
I bet they're all pedophiles because it
was just because it was,
if it was just,
if it was half of them or a quarter
home,
there would be busting each other out.
They would,
there would be people coming forward
saying,
we've got to stop this shit.
They're all covering each other's asses.
I mean,
think about it there.
They chose a job where they can get any
pussy.
Well,
the whole idea,
you know what I mean?
That's got to drive you insane.
And anybody who accepts a job where you
can get laid that you gotta be fucked up
already.
You already got.
And I think my,
my theory is that when these guys grow
up gay,
they're relieved,
they're grown up in a religious home.
That.
And then once they find out they're gay,
they realize,
Oh shit,
maybe Satan is inside of me.
I got these gay feelings.
Oh my God,
I gotta fight.
Same.
So they become ultra religious,
ultra Catholic,
and then they're trying to prove to God
that they're going to fight the gay.
They're gonna devote their life to God.
They become a priest and then Bam,
they hold it together for years.
And then they lose it.
You ever seen that video?
God hates fags.
No.
The Guy who,
uh,
who's a gay guy who was singing about
being Christian,
never seen that going to sign that shit.
You know what I gotta get the fuck out
of here.
I got to leave my man.
We don't have to leave for 20 minutes.
We leave the shower stuff.
Yeah.
But the fights don't even start for more
than hour.
And I got to get my hair did.
Come on,
man.
You're here.
It looks like you got to check this out
and people don't get to see you on
Youtube.
How long it takes to blow dry my hair.
Know how much you don't have to wash it
here.
Ten minutes.
Now.
Got to find this video because it's so
ridiculous.
It's a dude who's a gay dude who's
fighting
against it and he says,
Jesus is the only man for me.
It's just genius.
Hold on.
It's like A.
Those guys at Bora Bora Bora bought
Bruno fucks with God.
Hates fags on it's real.
This is a real song.
You have to see this because it's so god
damn genius.
This guy was the guy.
Here it is.
This is a real soft.
First of all,
his mustache.
A lot.
Hold on,
let me put this up to you guys.
I just put it up on twitter.
It's so stem.
He'll come on.
We'll look at the fucking mustache.
That's the proof is real.
This is a real fucking.
Sorry man.
This is so real.
Christian guy came in through the five
senses that we have is it's just not put
together.
You've got to go find and put all the
parts together,
but the world has,
you know,
how these feelings,
the helmet Razah bar and help them hear
me.
It's fucking mustache.
To be a gay dude and be religious and to
think that God hates you.
You can always be afraid if you haven't
seen that video,
you got to watch it because it's
completely ridiculous and by the way,
totally real.
You know the fucking dude is a,
is a gay guy who converted to
Christianity and he's like,
you know,
try to tell people the right way to go.
Wow.
It's pretty awesome.
It's pretty awesome stuff.
Where's your lighter?
Yeah,
put it up in the air,
Bro.
Well,
as get lighter considered.
Do we watch tim and Eric?
Yeah,
man.
Tim and Eric Rocks.
That's probably top three favorite
shows.
Not In celebrity rehab.
That fucking thing.
A dance floor.
Dale,
if you haven't seen that,
go do a google search for dance floor.
Dale is got to be one of the funniest
fucking videos I've ever seen in my
life.
The weirdest,
funniest things on the Internet ever.
Dance floor,
Dale,
you gotta.
See this gotTa,
find it,
find it.
It's online,
it's on my website.
You can find it on Joe Rogan.net
season three of 10 minute Erica,
because they keep having recurring
sketches and they just get funnier and
funnier the more the more developed.
Here's a good question for you.
What does Damien Maia and his Jujitsu
bring to the table that latest didn't?
Versus Silva because Damien Maia is
fighting Anderson Silva next month and
Abu Dhabi next week.
Dude,
I have a dummy next week.
I think Damien Maia is a better guard.
Poorer the Talus does talus would pull
guard,
but he wouldn't clench up first.
So you know,
filter doesn't.
It's not going to just fall in.
You got to really shoot deep with an
under hook and you've got to make the
guy sprawl and if he doesn't sprawl,
you know,
because you didn't take a deep shot,
you're not going to pull them into your
garden.
David Maya likes to shoot deep and pull
guard.
I think that'll be the difference.
There's no way he's going to stand with
Anderson Silva,
you know,
just based on,
not just based on Anderson Silva's
career and what he's done,
but based on his last fight where he
tried to stand for a little bit with
Nate Marquardt and he,
he's going to pull guard immediately.
Trust me.
He's not going to fuck around anymore.
That shit.
I hope that's true,
but I didn't think he was going to try
to stand with nate either.
Well,
they stood with them for one punch and
that was just one punch too long and
he's not going to.
He's training with vandelay and vandelay
brawler,
you know,
do you think that,
uh,
that style of getting in there and just
mixing it up and get ugly,
just not,
it's not a good style for a guy who was
not very technically proficient
instruction,
striking,
you know,
he's just so good on the ground.
Why give your opponent any kind of
chance,
especially Anderson Silva,
what are you going to try and mix it up
a little bit with them?
That's a big fucking mistake.
He's gonna.
Pull guard immediately.
Trust me or try to take them down
because,
you know,
Anderson Silva isn't some NCAA national
champion or anything,
so I'm sure Damien Maia is really going
to take a shot for real,
for real,
trying to take them down.
But if he has any trouble he will pull
guard.
No problem.
I guarantee that.
Yeah,
we've definitely seen Anderson been
taken down before it got taken down many
times by um,
uh,
travis luder now Travis Luder probably
had the most success.
But you gotta think about that fight.
Travis luder fought Anderson 11 weeks
after Anderson had knee surgery on both
knees,
so that probably wasn't the best
representation of his,
his,
his wrestling.
Then Dan Henderson took them down as
well and when Dan Henderson took him
down because he wasn't able to do
anything to let me just kind of like
held them down on the ground,
punched him a few times but really
couldn't get anything going.
No.
So that's the big question is,
is Anderson's Jujitsu good enough to
stifle a Damien Maia?
Because Damien Meyer had a hard time
with Dan Miller and his last fight
really couldn't get anything going with
them.
I mean he grounded,
pounded him and you know,
he'd beat them by decision but never
came close to finishing with a
submission.
No,
no.
And I think Dan Miller is a real good,
real tough guy,
but I think Anderson's Jujitsu is at
least as good as millers.
I mean on paper at least he's a black
belt
mothers of Rambo.
But Miller has wrestled his whole life.
There's a big difference.
That's a different kind of animal when
you're grappling with a real legit
wrestler.
And Anderson Silva has long limbs.
I like going with guys that have long
arms.
It's hard.
Rubber guards a lot easier with taller
guys.
It's harder for them to pull out of
anything.
I have long arms like the small one,
45 short five foot five,
stocky wrestler types.
That's hard to get any rubber guard on
because they popped their arms out
there,
you know,
out so easily.
They're really small.
So I think,
uh,
I think David Maya is going to have more
success with his Jujitsu,
with,
with Anderson Silva.
If he gets him to the ground then he did
with Miller because Miller again,
he's only a brown belt,
but damn,
he wrestled his whole life.
That's,
that's,
that's a different kind of animal right
there.
A chimpanzee
think about Anderson is that Anderson
has had elbow problems for years.
He's said a bone chunks floating around
his elbow that may training really
difficult.
He would have to ice his elbows after
training.
Sometimes it couldn't do any weight
lifting and strength and conditioning
because it's elbows hurt.
He finally got all that shit fixed.
You've got the elbow chunks,
the piece of bone taken out.
So we're going to see an Anderson Silva
that's in a better condition than we've
seen him in a long,
long time.
He's at a problem throwing his right
hand because of it,
which is really hard to believe when you
see his fights.
Big Country Nelson went tonight by fat
mission.
How dare you?
Let me tell you something,
man.
Fat.
A big guy like Roy Nelson,
he that waits centralized in his
stomach.
He knows that a hold you with that shit
that can keep you in a certain position.
He's really good at keeping his weight
on you.
We have a dude that we trained with
Brent grandkids inside control.
Man,
that motherfucker is really hard to get
off you and he's built similar to big
country,
not as fat,
but he's got a big gut and you know,
and he's talented as well.
He's a good Jujitsu guy and when he gets
on top of you and you know he gets a
good position on you,
is really hard to shake them off you.
He plants that weight down on you and
holds you in place and big country.
If I had to guess what's gonna Happen
Tonight?
What's truth?
You know,
I would say that big contract he gets
them down to ground is going to be a lot
of trouble.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But struve has a lot of potential.
He might be,
he might be the underdog in this fight.
He probably should be based on his
experience and is really young and
country's been grappling for a long time
and he's really good on the ground.
People haven't really seen that.
He likes to stand in back,
but country Nelson's really good on the
ground.
Really good.
Frank Mir,
was it like 11?
Nothing in a submission,
man.
Yeah.
He's really.
He's got a great half guard game too.
We just haven't really seen it.
But true in the long run has so much
potential.
I mean that guy that's like,
he's like 26,
eight or something like that.
He's super tall and he loves Jujitsu.
You never see that.
You never see tall guys like that who
were athletic and coordinated.
Love Jujitsu.
I mean you've seen.
We've seen 70 shell.
He didn't like Jiu Jitsu.
Um,
I don't know what other tall guy,
but you know,
random ran a Kendall grove.
That's another tall guy who likes to
Jitsu,
but he was true if he continues to
evolve and,
and remains a student of the game and
everything,
of course striking and wrestling as
well.
But in Jujitsu,
the way he's moving and you know,
we've talked several times about a
Jujitsu and strategy and philosophies
and stuff,
and he's on the right track.
He's that he,
he,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know if we can be country at
this point in his career.
Maybe,
maybe not,
but get that guy another five,
six,
seven years,
if it continues to evolve,
he can be a serious threat with that.
Would that height his guard could be
insane.
Yeah.
And he decided to be a Ninja office
back.
Fuck is only 22.
That's the other thing about that kid.
He's real young.
He's got a massive,
massive amount of time ahead of him,
you know,
and a lot of potential.
And he's got crazy heart.
Remember in Germany when you got cut
wide open.
I was bleeding all over the place.
And who did you fight that fight?
He got in trouble and you got cut real
bad and he still pulled it out and one
of submitting the dudes.
So it was uh,
it was pretty bad ass.
Do another youth stream tonight.
Maybe.
Maybe we will get back to the hotel,
it'll be late here and I don't go to bed
until late on the west coast,
so it will be early for me.
So yeah,
we can do that.
We could come after the after party and
do it,
do it.
Non Sober,
sober version of the dream because I got
to go do the broadcast and right now go
me or Ken Flo,
who the fuck knows sun?
That's why they got to do it.
I think it's exciting having gotten me
over here.
I would have liked to see them over here
years ago,
but,
you know,
he's still young and he's got a lot to
prove,
you know,
and I think uh,
he's training real hard.
He looked really in real good shape and
he's saying all the right things that he
wants to really make another run and get
another run at Bj Penn and he's
obviously got to get through Tennessee
to do that.
So I think going to be real interesting.
He's a solid wrestler and there's a big
power puncher,
you know,
he hits hard.
So,
uh,
I think Kenny's going to try to use his
legs.
He Kenny's got real good leg kicks,
real good movement.
He's going gonna try to use his
footwork,
working with leg kicks,
and then if it goes to the ground,
who tried to submit them and cut them up
with elbows.
The thing about Gomez Gomez has not
fought anybody ever with the elbow
rules.
You know,
elbows are different man,
especially the cage,
you know,
cage and elbows,
those are two totally different things
that he's never experienced before.
So it's going to be going to be
interesting.
That'll be interesting.
And Kenny,
man,
he gets better every time.
I gotta get Outta here guys.
I gotta get ready to shower.
You got to leave in 10 minutes.
Thank you very much.
I'll do this again.
Come over my house and we'll do a full
version.
All.
Alright.
You want to leave with us?
You know what?
I'm going to just take my own car and
got the rental.
I'll see you in 10 minutes.
No,
5:15.
It's only four or five right now.
Ladies and gentlemen.
And then
finally were alone.
So that's the story I got to leave in 10
minutes,
so I should,
I should uh,
get my shit going.
Yeah.
I wanted to do just a little shell
because I couldn't do one last week
because I had a staph infection that I
had to deal with so I didn't fucking
die.
That's the problem with Jujitsu,
man.
You know,
you role with 30 motherfuckers and get
weird skin shit,
you know,
we're diseases.
I know a to got herpes on his head.
What?
Yeah,
you can get a,
you can get herpes from Jujitsu.
Not Good.
The deal with me getting a Sirius radio
show,
I'm going to do a weekly show.
Uh,
I think I'm going to do like a six week
run,
a trial run and it's all dependent on my
scheduling because,
uh,
I just signed a deal to write a book.
I've been writing it for awhile but
they've been negotiating a deal and we
finally got the right deal.
And um,
I was in New York last week and I met
with the publishers and they came out to
see me when I performed at Gotham.
So,
uh,
I got a nice deal and I'm getting ready
and the deal is that I have to finish
the book by August,
so,
uh,
I'm going to be guns blazing trying to
write this thing and finish it and most
of the stories it's going to be mostly
about my,
uh,
the beginning days of doing standup
because I have so many crazy stories
about bad road gigs and just struggling
on the road and you know,
what it's like to be an really an
amateur comedian trying to,
you know,
go out there and get people to laugh for
money and you know,
and how fucking crazy it is and how
unsure it is and how you really have no
idea if it's ever going to work out and
you feel,
you know,
it's a completely insecure.
You know,
you feel like there's no way this is
ever going to really turn out to be a
career and how nutty some of the fucking
gigs I've done.
Well,
why wasn't you at weigh yesterday?
I don't even think I'm going to answer
that just because it's so retardedly
Britain.
Uh,
but if somebody else asks if I'll answer
it two ways because I didn't get any
time I got on my flight,
didn't lend until 4:00,
so they had Goldberg dual the weigh ins
and then,
uh,
I had my show last night.
Yeah,
because we were in New York and then I
flew back from New York Sunday.
I had Monday to stay home with my family
and then Tuesday flew out again.
So unless I'd stayed here in Charlotte,
there was no way really I was going to
be able to get to the weigh ins.
But no,
I didn't.
I didn't really,
uh,
this as too much traveling.
I need to be home at least a couple of
days a week.
Otherwise I go nutty when you have
babies,
man,
who just can't wait to go home and see
him,
you know.
Um,
how's hardees?
Hardees fine.
Hardy didn't have any problems.
There was nothing wrong with them.
I can't believe it.
Uh,
you know,
his shoulder,
his arms,
you know,
uh,
I think,
George St Pierre didn't quite have the
arm bar.
Right.
But,
uh,
the Camorra there was one point in time,
the more I thought it was just going to
rip off.
I mean it looked,
it looked pretty bad.
Bring back some chicks from the after
party at least.
No,
I can't do that anymore.
I made babies and I made it,
made a wife and all that.
All that shit.
When I do want to show the zs Enzo
Ferrari,
I don't know him,
but I think,
yeah,
I think he's on that show.
The Kevin being sure that I'm doing this
weekend,
April foolishness.
I think it's,
it's either Friday or Saturday night,
one of those.
I'm not sure which I'll tell you right
now.
Salary.
Yeah.
Saturday.
Except the Gibson amphitheater and
universal and I'm pretty sure it's way
sold out.
Those guys always sell out their shows.
It's a really good line up to a lot,
a lot of funny comedians.
I did it last year with Patton Oswald.
Did it.
Raven Ray Romano.
Patton Oswald.
Jeff Ross.
Uh,
a bunch of good guys.
I know Jeff's on it again this year.
I think Jay Morris out again this year
too.
Is error.
Yani,
hot or what?
She's hot,
if you're not gay,
if you're gay,
she's probably not the buffer.
Three 60 tonight.
I think he said he would never do that
again.
I think he said the buffer three is
going to retire and to put that shit in
the books,
it's over Sun.
What do I think about crop circles?
I think they're incredible geometric
patterns when they're not humans made
him.
Who the fuck knows,
you know,
I mean,
there's a lot of people that argue that
it's impossible for people to make them
that they've know three times the size
of a football field and they appear
overnight and they were in perfect
geometric patterns and circles and
everything.
I don't know know.
I think it's very intriguing,
you know,
at the very least some of them are
fascinating because there is so fucking
huge,
you know,
and if really,
I mean,
if people really are making these
things,
you know,
and uh,
they're flattening them out and just
leaving them there.
It's like,
wow,
there's such incredible geometric art.
You would think that they would want to
take credit for that.
You know,
if it's just a hoax,
it's incredible that it's a hoax that
they've kept up for this long.
Like how sneaky are they and what's the,
what's the benefit of that?
What's the,
uh,
what's the reward?
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't have an opinion one way or the
other though.
I,
um,
I think it's also possible that it could
be some sort of an experiment that they
do to impose geometric patterns in these
fields.
It might be something that they do,
you know,
from the sky or something like that.
And who the fuck knows how they're doing
it?
If you talk to some people that say that
these patterns,
the way they're made,
that the,
uh,
the,
the nodes of these plants have been
blown out.
Like they've had energy pulse through
them.
Like microwaves,
like expanded.
I don't know.
I don't know though.
I really personally have not done enough
research and really paid attention to
both sides of the argument.
I know one side of the argument is that
it's bullshit.
And the other side of the argument is
that it's aliens.
You know,
on both of them seem pretty ridiculous,
so I'm not,
I'm not exactly sure what I think about
that shit.
So what did I think about the Luke
Stewart Andre Galvao fight?
I thought that fight was really
interesting.
I was blown away by that.
Luke Stewart Guy.
That guy has incredible sweet man.
He's relentless.
I thought he won the fight.
I thought he beat him with stand up and
I thought his ground game and negated
golf vowels,
grand game and he swept him a bunch of
times and I thought he asked him,
you know,
I thought it was a real close fight,
but I thought a steward edge them.
But man,
he uh,
he blew me away.
Luke Stewart is a bad motherfucker and
I'm really looking forward to his next
fight.
That was really,
really impressive.
UFC One 15.
Cincinnati,
they say that might be possible if um,
if the,
the um,
Vancouver thing falls through.
I don't know if that's fallen through or
not A.
I haven't heard it directly from the
horse's mouth.
So when I hear it I'll find out
anymore documentaries like the union
coming out.
Yeah,
I did a documentary on Dmt,
it's called DMT,
the spirit molecule and it should be
done in May and probably out for release
sometime around the summer.
I know they're taking it to film
festivals and uh,
that bring it all over the place,
but it's a documentary mostly about
different people's experiences on dmt.
And I,
uh,
I'm the narrator.
So that's the deal.
Do I know who bob?
Yeah.
Bob was always that guy who claims to
have worked for area 51 and you know,
he's Kinda been discredited with a lot
of things,
especially like his education,
I guess he kinda like told some lies
about where he went to school and what
degrees are in,
but very,
very intelligent guy and obviously knew
a lot about that area,
about area 51,
whether or not he really did have any
contact with you,
fos or with alien spacecraft or any of
that stuff.
I mean it could be total 100 percent or
shit or it could be true.
I mean,
it's really hard to tell,
but when a guy who lies about his
education lies about certain aspects of
his background,
you kind of assume that he's probably
lied about other things as well,
you know,
I don't know.
Again,
I don't really have an opinion either
way.
Interesting to watch them talk though.
He's very confident,
you know,
he's very confident which could mean
either a who's crazy and that's why he's
confident or be.
He's telling the truth.
I'm alright.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here because,
uh,
the car is picking me up in two minutes.
I just wanted to,
uh,
to bust out a nice quick one right here
for you guys and say what's up?
So,
um,
thank you everybody for tuning in and
we'll do one probably this weekend.
I'll have eddie come over to my house
and we'll do like a full long ass one,
maybe Friday.
And that's it,
my friends.
Thank you very much.
Enjoy the fights tonight.
There are live on spike TV tonight.
There's a,
I don't know what time it comes on,
but it's right before the ultimate
fighter.
So it's fight night Kenny Florian versus
go me is the headline or it's going to
be a sick,
sick fight and Ross Pearson's on the car
to,
against dentists are looking forward to
that too.
All right,
my friends,
thank you very much for tuning into this
thing again and uh,
I will be back next week with a real,
a solid podcast.
Uh,
and maybe we'll even do one this weekend
with Eddie Bravo at my house.
So thank you very much.
And uh,
I'll see you guys soon.
Thanks.